[Musique]
la question était suivante nous sommes
dans un pays où il ya 700 milliards de
dépenses sociales certains disent 15% du
pipe mondiale et pourtant rapport après
rapport la pauvreté ne fait qu'augmenter
et nous croisons tous les jours de plus
en plus dans la rue dans le métro des
gens qui ont une pancarte avec marc et
j'ai faim donc ma question est très
simple mais où est passé tout cet argent
vous avez si la courbe exponentielle de
dépenses des prestations sociales et à
côté quelqu'un qui a la bonne idée de ne
pas nous emmerder avec son accordéon
mais qui a besoin d'argent pour survivre
alors où est passé l'argent et bien il
est passé dans les rouages d'une machine
bureaucratique extrêmement complexe
construite avec beaucoup de bonnes
intentions décennie après décennie et
qui superpose différentes dispositif
d'allocation et comme toujours avec ses
machines complexes vous avez des insider
qui la connaissent très bien qu'ils en
profitent largement et vous avez d
outsider qui sont laissés totalement à
l'écart
pour vous donner une idée pour gérer
aujourd'hui les 90 milliards de
prestations de base il faut 18000 règles
de droit c'est les minima sociaux en
france aujourd'hui c'est ça et encore
c'est la petite partie émergée de
l'iceberg
donc la question plus fondamentale plus
philosophique en un sens c'est pourquoi
a t'on construit ça on a construit ça
parce que ce système dead est basée sur
l'identité des gens il faut définir qui
ils sont quels sont leurs besoins
quelles sont leurs aspirations
quelle est leur vie de couple et qui dit
identité dit vérification qui dit
vérification dit contrôle qui dit
contrôler 10 injustice aujourd'hui pour
percevoir le minimum du minimum
le rsa qui d'environ pour le rsa socle
500 euros vous devez aller passer des
entretiens au caf
les caf ce sont les caisses
d'allocations familiales
quel rapport ça vous dit tout sur
l'étendue du paternalisme qui régit
notre système social
aujourd'hui quand vous demander le rsa
vous devez remplir un formulaire de dix
pages qui fait que entre un tiers et
deux tiers de ses allocataires
potentiels le demande pas vous devez
passer des entretiens qui peuvent être
particulièrement humiliant discriminant
vous est étiqueté comme pauvres puis
ensuite on peux vous en donner trop
arias des procès pour un du rsa comme
les somnifères si c'est si vous êtes en
famille si le asahi familialiser pour
vous demander d'en rendre une partie on
peut même aller contrôler que vous êtes
bien encore plus quand même des attendus
de procès pour un du rsa ou on va
vérifier si oui ou non il ya deux
brosses à dents dans le même verre ce
qui vaut à dire que les personnes ne
sont pas qu'aux locataires mais
véritablement en couple bref c'est un
système intrusif
est ce que nous vivons tous on prend
avec la bureaucratie tous les jours les
personnes en difficulté le vivent
d'autant plus est d'autant plus mal
alors comme toujours quand il ya un
problème de société les poètes les
poètes de l'époque s'en empare en
l'occurrence récemment virginie
despentes et ken loach dans son dernier
roman vernon subutex premier volume
virginie despentes décrit la longue
descente aux enfers de la victime
parfaite de notre temps vernon subutex
vernon subutex disquaires ruminer donc
par l'irruption du numérique
n'ayant pas droit à un certain nombre de
prestations parce que c'est un
indépendant un entrepreneur qui se
retrouve finalement au rsa et qui perd
un jour le rsa parce que au hasard d'une
conversation avec sa conseillère caf
il a laissé échapper que oui il lui
arrivait d'aller voir un concert avec
cet argent et que donc ils n'ont ils
n'étaient pas forcément en recherche
d'emploi
aujourd'hui pour percevoir le rsa ya un
certain nombre de conditionnalité si
vous ne remplissez pas vous pouvez en
être exclu ce qui arrive à vernon
j'ajoute que si vous reprenez un emploi
et que vous êtes chauffé ruber pendant
deux mois vous perdez le bénéfice du rsa
qu'il faudra les recommandés l'autre ken
loach vient de sortir sur les écrans
français son film moi daniel blake qui
dans un autre contexte et dans un autre
pays décrit à peu près la même chose
n'était pas le mot d'or à cannes l'année
dernière et je vous propose d'en voir un
extrait ok désolé quand tu joues à part
le fait qu'ils aient l'accent de
newcastle c'est un film très parlants et
qui vous montre à quel point les gens
sont traités comme des enfants alors la
solution qui peut être proposé pour
remédier à ces phénomènes
c'est le revenu universel pour le
définir de manière extrêmement simple il
s'agit de données de chaque personne
majeure de 18 ans à sa mort
une somme d'argent qui lui permettent de
survivre sans condition
sans contrôle et sans aucune
contrepartie cette somme est déterminé
comme la somme qui vous permet de
survivre dignement dans une société
donnée est attribué à chaque membre de
la société alors nous demanderez
peut-être qu'elle sur quels fondements
philosophiques on peut défendre une idée
aussi baroque il y en a beaucoup je vous
en propose deux parce que ce sont deux
personnages de la même époque qui ont
tous les deux participé à la révolution
française le premier l'échevelé à gauche
c'est gracchus babeuf l'égalitarisme
celui qui voulait non seulement un
revenu minimum est aussi un revenu
maximum et que de préférence ils
coïncident
c'est la version qui existe encore
aujourd'hui la version collectiviste la
version socialiste du revenu de base
et puis vous avez à droite thomas spain
vous voyez qu'il a l'air nettement plus
sympathique
thomas spain et disons un libéral mais
il a un parcours très intéressant c'est
un britannique intéressés par la
déclaration des droits de l'homme en
france ayant répondu à burke qui la
critiquaient émigré aux états unis où il
a participé à la révolution américaine
dont il est parfois considéré comme un
des pères fondateurs et ensuite réfugiée
en france où cette fois il va participer
à la révolution française
au point d'être le premier étranger
naturalisé français élu à l'assemblée
nationale en 1792 et thomas spain
conceptualisant la justice agraire les
linéaments d'un revenu universel tel
qu'on l'entend aujourd'hui et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que sa double culture
anglo saxonne et française fait qu' il
cherche à réconcilier rousseau et locke
de rousseau il retient l'idée que au
début dans l'état de nature et y ait une
certaine égalité entre les hommes
égalité vis-à-vis des ressources
naturelles et que nous avons cet
héritage en partage et que les
inégalités de ce point de vue là sont
une forme d'injustice par rapport à
cette égalité primordial
mais de l'ocs il retient l'idée que
l'enrichissement la transformation la
transformation de la nature en valeur la
valorisation des produits
la possibilité de créer de s'attacher
des biens par la propriété est tout à
fait louable et permet les progrès de la
civilisation et c'est donc pour
réconcilier les deux qu'il propose son
revenu universel en disant nous allons
vous compenser pour la perte de votre
héritage naturel et comme cet héritage
est le même pour tous et bien cette
somme sera la même pour tous et il a une
phrase qui je trouve résume très bien sa
philosophie
je me fiche que certains deviennent très
riche du moment que personne ne devient
pauvre en conséquence de sorte que ce
revenu ne sera plus considérée comme une
charité mais comme un droit un droit qui
dit il viendra compléter la déclaration
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen
alors vous êtes en droit de me dire
aujourd'hui c'est un peu utopique
d'abord j'aimerais préciser que je
déteste les utopies je vous recommande
de lire d'ailleurs la première du genre
l'utopia de thomasz mort qui est un
véritable enfer ou la longueur des rues
est déterminée par l'état et où les
activités de chacun sont contrôlées à
leur prêt une utopie c'est toujours le
fantasme de quelqu'un imposer au reste
de la société
le revenu universel n'est pas une utopie
d'abord parce qu'il ne résout pas il ne
propose pas de plans d'ensemble ne
propose pas de vision la société il ne
propose pas de valeurs communes c'est
tout le contraire il donne à chacun la
possibilité en lui donnant son minimum
d'autonomie de déterminer ses propres
choix de vie de déterminer sa propre
définition de la vie bonne
en un sens la société avec le revenu
universel atteint tel point de
sophistication qu'elle donne la
possibilité à ses membres de s'en
soustraire et deuxièmement ce n'est pas
une utopie
parce qu'aujourd'hui en france il est
très réaliste et je vais rentrer un peu
dans le détail des chiffres il est très
réaliste parce que nous avons accumulé
tellement de prestations nous avons un
système tellement redistributif que
passer au revenu universel ça serait
changer les tuyaux mais ça serait pas
changé la masse des transferts
financiers ça ne provoquera aucun
bouleversement économique dans le pays
ça changerait seulement marginalement
l'argent que les gens perçoivent ou
qu'ils payent sous forme d'impôts c'est
très bien expliqué par lionel stoléru
qui est l'avocat du revenu universel
depuis les années 70 qu'il avait importé
des états unis eau friedman l'avait
remis au goût du jour
et si vous parlez est les rues il vous
dira que la longue série des grandes
réformes sociales rmi ni bpe rsa prime
d'activité va dans le sens du revenu
universel qui est l'aboutissement
logique de cette série donc les
conditions sont là à quoi
ressemblerait-il nous avons travaillé
avec des économistes qui ont modélisé
tout cela est donc je vais passer très
rapidement sur le détail peut vous
donner la conclusion la conclusion c'est
que vous pourriez avoir un coût constant
un revenu universel qui est une sorte de
super rsa
encore une fois c'est pas la lune ça ne
résout pas tous les problèmes mais si
vous faites un revenu universel de 500
euros l'équivalent du rsa aujourd'hui en
mettant le logement de côté donc un
revenu universel qui couvre les besoins
de consommation courante consommation
nourriture logement énergie
télécommunications transport vous
l'évaluez à 500 euros
vous devez pour lui financé par un impôt
qui se substituent lui à l'impôt sur le
revenu de 25 % sur l'ensemble des
revenus pas rien tout de même
et que vous avez un schéma où en fait
c'est 500 euros attribuée donc à chaque
individu chaque mois prenne la forme
d'un crédit d'impôt et puis vous avez
pour compenser pour financer ce système
pour qu'il soit l équilibre cet impôt
sur le revenu à 25%
et chacun fait la différence à la fin du
mois entre l'impôt qu'il doit le 25 % et
le crédit d'impôt qui lui est dû les 500
euros de sorte que si vous touchez 0 eh
bien vous touchez les 500 euros en cash
et là vous êtes libres de les utiliser
de la manière que vous voulez sans
rendre de comptes à personne et sans
avoir à les demander en sachant que
c'est un droit non chacun bénéficie si
vous devez 1 millions d'impôts vous ne
devrez plus que 999 1500 et tous les cas
intermédiaires sont possibles donc si
vous devez si vous touchez par exemple
1000 euros eh bien vous devrez payer 250
d'impôts et vous aurez votre crédit
d'impôt de 500 et donc vous toucherez au
final de 150 en plus donc c'est un
système dans lequel comme toujours il y
en a qui paye
il y en a qui reçoivent mais simplement
s'est fait sur une base beaucoup plus
équitable
d'où la question suivante bien légitime
pourquoi madame que chacun pourra
reconnaître devrait-elle touché le
revenu universel
je dirais d'abord c'est ce qui lui
permettra de survivre quand sa fille il
y aura tout piqué mais blague à part
vous voyez bien que le revenu universel
et en quelque chose que vous voyez
chaque mois sur votre feuille de revenus
ou même d'ailleurs sur vos impôts
même si vous n'en bénéficie pas
directement parce que le montant des
impôts et bien au delà du montant du
crédit d'impôt c'est quelque chose qui
reste avec vous toute votre vie
de sorte que l' angoisse de la grande
pauvreté disparaît et souvent quand
j'expose ce système j'ai des réactions
de personnes au rsa qui me disent pour
moi votre système ne changerait pas
grand chose économiquement parlant
financièrement mais ça changerait tout
dans ma vie parce que je cesserai d'être
un quémandeur professionnels
j'aurai une stabilité et une visibilité
sur l'argent que je reçois et je pouvais
faire quelque chose de plus intéressant
de ma vie que d'aller au caf c'est aucun
système extrêmement vertueux parce que
d'abord il élimine de manière
automatique et radicale la grande
pauvreté plus jamais vous ne verrez
quelqu'un un résident légal sur le
territoire
aucun panneau j'ai faim impossible
deuxièmement il simplifie de manière
extrêmement égalitaire et simple
transparente
le système de location d'un côté et des
impôts de l'autre troisièmement il
permet que le travail paye toujours
puisque dans un tel système
dès que vous gagnez plus et bien vos
allocations diminuent de 75% par euro
gagnent enfin il permet que tout le
monde paye l'impôt fussent virtuellement
chacun reçoit mais chacun contribue et
j'ajouterais qu'il est particulièrement
bien adapté un monde post dit post
salariale où les gens peuvent exercer
une pluralité d'activités différentes et
donc dont les revenus sont discontinue
de mois en mois c'est un filet de
sécurité qui s'ajuste de manière
immédiate en temps réel à la disparité
des revenus des individus pour malgré
qu'il ya des choses dont je ne vous ai
pas parlé je ne vous ai pas parlé de la
fin du travail de la robotisation des
communs collaboratif et cetera
certains technophiles fond de l'argument
du revenu universel sur l'idée que nous
allons tirer une rente sur les robots
tout ça c'est bien joli mais on n'a pas
besoin de cette réflexion pour passer au
revenu universel parce que le revenu
universel
ça peut être ici et maintenant en france
en 2017
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]